With over four decades of Star Wars movies,
books and TV shows to pore over, fans have
uncovered a myriad of mistakes and inconsistencies
in the universe over the years.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here
and in this video, I'll be explaining how
the new Solo film addresses or fixes five
intriguing Star Wars movie mistakes, contradictions
and unanswered questions.
If you're new here, I do regular movie breakdowns,
so subscribe to get all my new Star Wars videos
and leave a comment as well for a chance to
win a Star Wars Funko Pop!
Spoilers ahead for the Solo movie, so take
care if you haven't seen it yet.
Something that's puzzled die-hard Star Wars
fans for a while is how the Millennium Falcon
can have a conversation with droids like C3PO
and R2-D2?
"Sir, I don't know where your ship learned
to communicate, but it has the most peculiar
dialect."
"I believe, sir, it says that the power coupling
on the negative axis has been polarized."
And the Solo movie finally reveals that it's
Lando's cranky droid L3 who's behind the Millennium
Falcon's rather quirky personality.
After L3 kicks off a droid rebellion on Kessel,
she gets blasted and her system starts failing.
Lando manages to save part of her and takes
her onto the Millennium Falcon.
During their escape, the crew have to take
a shortcut through the Maelstrom which is
extremely dangerous, but Han points out that
L3 has "the best navigational database in
the galaxy" and suggests downloading her brain
into the Falcon's computer.
L3 then maps the area and finds the best way
out.
So in the words of Lando, she's "a part of
the ship now."
This also fits something revealed in The Last
Jedi novelisation where it's said that "the
Falcon has always been cantankerous" and that
one of its brains "had a fondness for both
romantic gossip and dirty jokes" which fits
in well with L3's personality as we saw it
in the Solo movie.
It might also explain why Lando is still protective
of the ship when we meet him in The Empire
Strikes Back as it still houses the consciousness
so to speak of his old friend.
By the way, L3's brain module originated as
an R3 astromech brain which also ties in neatly
with the specs for the Millennium Falcon which
state the ship's computer is made up of 3
droid brains one of which is an R3 astromech.
When we first meet Han Solo in A New Hope,
he boasts about how the Millennium Falcon
made the Kessel Run in under 12 parsecs.
Since then though canon stories have thrown
doubt on whether Han's achievement is actually
true.
In the canon novel "A New Hope: The Princess,
The Scoundrel, and The Farm Boy", it's revealed
that when Han makes his boast in the Mos Eisley
cantina, it's actually a lie and that Obi-Wan
probably knew better.
And amusingly, by the time of The Force Awakens,
it seems that Rey's heard stories that it
actually took around 14 parsecs.
"This is the ship that made the Kessel Run
in 14 parsecs?"
"Twelve!"
"(SCOFFS) Fourteen."
The Solo movie weighs in on the confusion
when, after completing the run, Han boasts
to the guy handling the fuel cells that he
just did the Kessel Run in 12 parsecs.
Then Chewie seems to object to this claim,
and Han replies, "not if you round down, buddy".
Now, exactly how much rounding-down is going
on here isn't revealed, but it sounds like
those 14 parsecs mentioned in The Force Awakens
might be closer to the truth than fans thought
when we first saw that scene.
If you watch or more accurately listen to
a Star Wars movie, you'll start to notice
that names are often pronounced inconsistently,
something due in part to the mix of American
and British actors and their differing accents.
And there's one major character in particular
whose name's been said inconsistently throughout
the movies.
"Han Solo."
"Well, take care of yourself Han."
"What?"
"Han..."
"It sounds like Han."
"There's still a chance to save Han..."
"Oh, it's Han."
"you think that after what you did to Han"
"Han, we need you."
"nor was giving Han to this bounty hunter!"
"What about Han?"
"Han, get up here!"
"Han?!"
"We're trying to save Han from the bounty
hunter!"
"Princess, we'll find Han."
"We're short one Han Solo."
"You're Han Solo?"
"Goodness!
Han Solo!"
"You are the Han Solo that fought with the
Rebellion."
"Han Solo!"
In the original trilogy, many American actors
say "Hon", while British actors pronounce
it "Han", Carrie Fisher's Leia switches between
"Hon" and "Han", George Lucas himself says
"Han" and Lando repeatedly pronounces it "Han"
despite Billy Dee Williams being American.
The Solo movie decides to acknowledge this
inconsistency, explaining it in the scene
where Han meets Lando for the first time.
"Han Solo."
"Can I ask you a question Captain Calrissian?"
"Anything Han."
"It's Han.
But that's OK."
Perhaps Lando was just trying to put Han off
his game, but it seems like the pronunciation
stuck and we now have an explanation for the
way Lando says it.
Rogue One already gave us a little theory
about why Stormtroopers so often miss their
targets when it comes to Force users, but
the Solo movie takes the explanation a stage
further and answers the perennial question
of how imperial troops can be so generally
incompetent when shooting even people who
aren't Force sensitive.
In a bit of meta-commentary, after removing
a Mudtrooper uniform, Jon Favreau's alien
character Rio says, "How do they breathe in
these suits?
It's so stuffy.
No wonder they're such lousy pilots.
You can't turn your head, you can't breathe,
you can't hear each other."
Obviously, he's not directly addressing Stormtrooper
incompetence rather Mudtroopers, but it seems
reasonable to assume that Stormtroopers also
suffer from having to wear clunky, stuffy
suits as well, hence the reason for their
infamous inability to shoot accurately.
At the end of Solo, the movie tackles the
controversial change that George Lucas made
when he re-edited the original Star Wars for
the 1997 Special Edition re-release.
Lucas altered the scenes in the cantina where
bounty hunter Greedo corners Han about the
money he owes Jabba.
Originally, after Han said "over my dead body",
Greedo bragged that he "looking forward to
this", prompting Han to shoot him dead.
George Lucas was unhappy with this portrayal
of Han saying it showed him to be a "cold-blooded
killer", so for the 1997 release he added
frames showing Greedo shooting Han first but
missing.
Curiously, the 2004 DVD release edited the
scene again having Greedo and Han shoot at
each other around the same time.
The Solo movie heavily implies that Han most
probably did shoot first in the cantina, because
he does the same to Beckett, shooting him
dead as he's talking and readying his own
gun.
Solo sets Han's character up as someone operating
in a morally-grey area, both willing to help
out the good guys like Enfys Nest and also
work for people like Jabba the Hut.
And it's Han's transition from rogue to hero
in A New Hope that many fans love about the
character which is why it feels important
that Solo finally establishes that Han did
shoot first.
Solo was absolutely packed with Star Wars
easter eggs and connections, so were there
any other issues you spotted that the movie
fixed or answered?
And did you notice any new plot holes in the
movie?
Let me know in the comments and make sure
you're subscribed to enter my Star Wars Funko
Pop giveaway.
If you enjoyed this, I really appreciate a
thumbs-up and you sharing the video, plus
you can tap left for my breakdown of what
Darth Maul's reveal means for an Obi-Wan movie
or tap right for my full Star Wars playlist.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers.